dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly Jean IIFA here this
is a matter one of those amazing papers
that I am really excited about and the
reason for that is that this is in the
intersection of computer graphics and
machine learning which as you know is
already enough to make me happy but when
I first seen the quality of the results
I was delighted to see that it delivered
exactly what I was hoping for life
simulation programs are an important
subfield of computer graphics where we
try to create a photorealistic image of
a 3d digital scene by simulating the
path of millions and millions of light
rays first we start out with a noisy
image and as we compute more paths it
slowly clears up however it takes a very
long time to get a perfectly clear image
and depending on the scene and the
algorithm it can take from minutes to
hours in an earlier work we had a
beautiful but pathological scene that
took weeks to render on several machines
if you would like to hear more about
that the link is available in the video
description so in order to alleviate
this problem many noise filtering
algorithms surfaced over the years the
goal of these algorithms is that instead
of computing more and more paths until
the image clears up we stopped at a
noisy image and try to guess what the
final image would look like this often
happens in the presence of some
additional depth and geometry
information additional images that are
often referred to as feature buffers or
auxiliary buffers this information helps
the noise filter to get a better
understanding of the scene and produce
higher-quality outputs recently a few
learning based algorithms emerged with
excellent results well excellent would
be an understatement
since these can take an extremely noisy
image that we rendered with one array
per pixel this is as noisy as it gets
I'm afraid and it is absolutely stunning
that we can still get usable images out
of this however these algorithms are not
capable of dealing with sequences of
data and are condemned to deal with each
of these images in isolation they have
no understanding of the fact that we are
dealing with an animation what does this
mean exactly what this means is that the
network has no memory of how it dealt
with the previous image and if we
combine it with the fact that a trace
amount
of noise still remains in the images we
get a disturbing flickering effect this
is because the remainder of the noise is
different from image to image this
technique uses a recurrent neural
network which is able to deal with
sequences of data for instance in our
case video it remembers how it dealt
with the previous images a few moments
ago and as a result it can adjust and
produce outputs that are temporally
stable computer graphics researchers
like to call this spatio-temporal
filtering you can see in this camera
panning experiment how much smoother
this new technique is let's try the same
footage slow down and see if we get a
better view of the flickering
yep all good recurrent neural networks
are by no means easy to train and need
quite a few implementation details to
get it right so make sure to have a look
at the paper for details temporarily
coherent light simulation reconstruction
of noisy images from one sample per
pixel and for video this is insanity I
would go out on a limb and say that in
the very near future we'll run
learning-based noise filters that take
images that are so noisy they don't even
have one raised sample per pixel maybe
one every other pixel or so this is
going to be the new milestone if someone
told me that this would be possible when
I started doing light transport as an
undergrad student I wouldn't have
believed a word of it computer games VR
and all kinds of real-time applications
will be able to get photorealistic light
simulation graphics in real-time and
temporally stable I need to take some
time to digest this thanks for watching
and for your generous support and I'll
see you next time
[Music]